400 الف جندي روسي اضافي الى جبهات القتال
نهايه هذا العام تعبئه جديده تخطط لها
وزاره الدفاع الروسيه منذ الاول من المقبل
وحمله تجنيد قوامها متطوعون تسعى الى
تعزيز القوه البشريه في الجيش الروسي
بنسبه 50% وفقا لتقارير محليه
التقارير افادت بان وزاره الدفاع الروسيه
ابلغت رؤساء الاقاليم بقرار التعبئه وبعدد
المجندين الذين يتعين عليهم تجهيزهم مع
نهايه العام
كما شوهد مسؤولون عسكريون في المناطق
القريبه من الحدود مع اوكرانيا يوزعون
مذكرات استدعاء على السكان طالبوهم بتحديث
بياناتهم بمكاتب التجنيد وفقا لبي بي بي
سي روسيا
وسائل اعلام روسيه اخرى ذكرت ان الجيش
الروسي ينتظر من المجندين الجدد ان يكونوا
ذوي قدره على تشغيل المدرعات والمدفعيه
خاصه بعد تقارير سابقه اشارت الى ان الذين
تلقوا تدريبا محدودا قتلوا بشكل جماعي وفي
حاله تنفيذ هذه التعبئه تكون الاخيره
تناقضت مع تصريح سابق لوزير الدفاع الروسي
فبراير الماضي نف فيه اي خطط لتعبئه ثانيه
يذكر ان موسكو في سبتمبر الماضي اعلنت عن
تعبئه جزئيه ل 300 الف من جنود الاحتياط
[موسيقى]